do you think uh tesla or waymo or some
of these companies that are doing
uh semi or fully autonomous driving
should be doing driver sensing
yes are you thinking about that kind of
stuff so not just how we can enhance
the in-cab experience for cars that are
mainly driven but the ones that are
increasingly more autonomously driven
yes so if we fast forward to the
universe where it's fully autonomous i
think interior sensing becomes extremely
important because the role of the driver
isn't just to drive if you think about
the driver almost manages
manages the dynamics within a vehicle
and so who's going to play that role
when it's an autonomous
car we want a solution that is able to
say oh my god like you know lex is bored
to death because the car's moving way
too slow let's engage lex or ron is
freaking out because she doesn't trust
this vehicle yet so let's tell rana like
a little bit more information about the
route or right so i think
or or somebody's having a heart attack
in the car like you need interior
sensing in fully autonomous vehicles
but with semi-autonomous vehicles i
think it's
i think it's really key to have driver
monitoring because semi-autonomous means
that sometimes the car is in charge
sometimes the driver is in charge or the
co-pilot right and you need this you
need both systems to be on the same page
you need to know the car needs to know
if the driver's asleep before it
transitions control over to the driver
and sometimes if the driver's too tired
the car can say
i'm going to be a better driver than you
are right now i'm taking control over so
this dynamic this dance is so key and
you can't do that without driver sensing
yeah there's a disagreement for the
longest time i've had to dylan that this
is obvious that this should be in the
tesla from day one and it's obvious that
driver sensing
is not a hindrance
it's not obvious
i should be careful because
having studied this problem
nothing is really obvious but it seems
very likely driver sensing is not a
hindrance to an experience it's only
enriching to the experience
and likely increases the safety that
said
it is very surprising to me
just having studied
semi-autonomous driving how well humans
are able to manage that dance because it
was
the intuition before you were doing that
kind of thing that
humans will become
just
incredibly distracted they would just
like let the thing do its thing
but they're able to you know because it
is life and death right and they're able
to manage that somehow but that said
there's no reason not to have driver
sensing on top of that i feel like
that's going to
allow you to do that dance
that you're currently doing without
driver sensing except just touching the
steering wheel
to do that even better i mean the
possibilities are endless and the
machine learning possibilities are such
a such a beautiful
it's also a constrained environment so
you can do a much more effectively than
you can with the external environment
right external environment is full of
weird edge cases and complexities this
inside there's so much it's so
fascinating such a fascinating world i i
do hope that
companies like tesla and others even
even waymo
um which i don't even know if waymo's
doing anything sophisticated inside the
cab i don't think so it's like hey
like what what what is it
i honestly think i honestly think it
goes back to the robotics thing we were
talking about which is like
great engineers that are building these
ai systems
just are afraid of the human being and
not thinking about the human experience
they're thinking about the features and
yeah the perceptual abilities of that
thing they think the best way i can
serve the human is by
doing the best perception and control i
can by looking at the external
environment keeping the humans safe
right but like there's a huge i'm here
right like uh
you know i i i need to be uh noticed and
um
interacted with and understood and all
those kinds of things even just on a
personal level for entertainment
honestly for entertainment yeah
um you know one of the coolest work we
did in collaboration with mit around
this was we looked at longitudinal data
right of drive because because you know
mit had access to like
tons of data um and we and and like just
seeing the patterns of people like
driving in the morning versus off to
work versus like commuting back from
work or weekend driving versus weekday
driving
and is wouldn't it be so cool if your
car knew that and then was able to
optimize
either the route or the experience or
even make recommendations yeah i think
it's very powerful yeah like why are you
taking this route you're always unhappy
when you take this route and you're
always happy when you take this
alternative route take that route
instead exactly that i mean that if to
have that even that little step
a relationship with a car i think is is
in
incredible of course you have to get the
privacy right you have to get all that
kind of stuff right but yeah i wish i i
honestly you know people are paranoid
about this but i would like a smart
refrigerator
we have a such
a deep connection with food as a human
civilization
i would like to have a
a refrigerator
that would understand me
that you know i also have a complex
relationship with food because like you
know
pig out too easily and all that kind of
stuff so you try you know uh
like maybe i want the refrigerator to be
like are you sure about this because
maybe you're just feeling down or tired
like maybe maybe less sleep
the smart refrigerator is way kinder
than mine is it just me and yelling at
you no it was just because i i don't i
don't um
you know i don't drink alcohol i don't
smoke but i eat a ton of chocolate like
it sticks my vice
and so i and and sometimes ice cream too
and i'm like okay my smart refrigerator
will just like lock down they'll just
say dude you've had way too many today
like
yeah no but here's the thing
are you do you regret having
like
let's say not the next day but 30 days
later
would you what would you what would you
like to the refrigerator to have done
then
well i think actually like the more
positive relationship would be one where
there's a conversation right as opposed
to like for that's probably like the
more
sustainable relationships it's like
late at night just no listen listen i
know i told you an hour ago right that
is not a good idea but just listen
things have changed i can just ima
imagine a bunch of stuff being made up
just to convince
hilarious uh but i mean i just
think that there's opportunities there i
mean maybe not locking down but
for our systems that are such
uh deep part of our lives like we use
uh we use a lot of us
uh a lot of people that commute use
their car every single day a lot of us
use a refrigerator every single day the
microwave every single day like we just
like
i feel like certain things could be made
more efficient more enriching
and ai is there
to help like some just basic recognition
of of you as a human being about your
patterns about what makes you happy and
not happy and all that kind of stuff and
the car obviously
maybe maybe maybe we'll say wait
instead of this like
gen
benjary's ice cream how about this
hummus and carrots or something i don't
know maybe wouldn't make it like yeah
like a just in time recommendation right
but not like a generic one but a
reminder that last time you chose the
carrots
you smiled seventeen times more than
that happier the next day right yeah
you're happier the next day and uh
and but yeah i don't but then again if
you're the kind of person that that gets
better from negative
negative comments you could say like hey
remember like that wedding you're going
to
you want to fit into that dress
remember about that
let's think about that right before
you're eating this no i don't it's for
some probably that would work for me
like a refrigerator that is just
ruthless it's shaming me but like i
would of course welcome it like right
that would that would work for me just
that that well i would know i think it
would if it's really like smart it would
optimize its nudging based on what works
for you right exactly that's the whole
point personalization right in every way
depersonalization
you